on va vous dévoiler cette saison qui
expliquent le théâtre reprend vie malgré
la pandémie au théâtre du nouveau monde
ça veut dire cet automne des formats
plus intimes dont une collaboration avec
l'orchestré métropolitain
je rentrais de vanter les bienfaits de
la pandémie mais quand même dire que
dans un contexte comme ça c'est
peut-être le moment aussi d'avoir des
projets auxquels on n'aurait pas pensé
normalement ce qu'on voit présentement
c'est la résilience des gens
l'imagination la solidarité dans le
milieu avoue françois il se réveille du
théâtre se fera un peu partout au québec
lit dans des salles aux trois quarts
vides à cause de la distanciation d'un
mètre et demi au tnm
il y aura un maximum de 160 spectateurs
saivet % de la capacité maximale un
premier pas en avant bien sûr c'est pas
l'idéal ça peut faire souffler un vent
d'espoir autant sur le public que sur
nos artistes qui ont besoin de
travailler j'avoue moins que j'aime
jouer dans de vains peu de gens je
trouve l'écouté before des fois les
côtes se dispersent
ça c'est mon siège m'asseoir et voilà au
théâtre la licorne le manque à gagner
sera important car ce sont des rangées
entières qui ont disparu on va avoir 50
places sur une salle de 180 places on
enlève une rangée sur deux donc pour
nous c'est assez simple c'est très aéré
je viens juste de justement de voir la
salle réaménagée
après une saison de rêve en 2019 2020
chez duceppe remonte en selle à
l'automne avec des spectacles solos et
un gros plan b on va toujours avoir deux
des quatre sur scène et dépendamment de
la demande du public dépendamment de est
ce que quelqu'un tombe malade s'il
arrive quoi que ce soit on peut tourner
le décor de barrer un autre production
qui va arriver le lendemain on avis des
spectateurs et on va de l'avant avec nos
productions donc on fait attention de
pas trop perdre d'argent
les théâtres de broc en effet se serrer
la ceinture dans les mois à venir car
moins de public veut dire moins de
revenus on s'inquiète aussi
de haut niveau au niveau financier la
survie financière de ces compagnies là
notamment les plus petites salles les
plus petites compagnies productrices
aussi donc ça reste quand même
inquiétant pour nous l'automne sera
aussi numérique pour les théâtres
car le gouvernement du québec annonce
une aide financière 2 millions de
dollars à la compagnie jean duceppe pour
développer de la webdiffusion pour les
théâtre québécois avec l'outil du
numérique qu'on a mis dans le plan de
relance dont on va pouvoir faire un très
beau coup plus de monde en direct dans
leur salon et qui vont payer pour voir
ces pièces est ce que le numérique est
une panacée pour le théâtre il pourrait
y avoir plus de la ministre le tout est
sur la table actuellement et je discute
actuellement avec mon homologue au
fédéral en ce qui a trait à une forme de
mesure qui pourrait nous aider
d'une certaine façon à compenser le
manque de spectateurs en salles dont
huit en négociation c'est assez
formidable que vous soyez tous là
vraiment avec tous ces maux de tête et
les défis reliés à la pandémie
les créateurs espèrent des jours
meilleurs c'est pas la première crise
des crises de théâtre combien de fois on
nous annoncer la mort du tr à tout le
monde de l'opéra
moi je tenais optimise son rôle quand tu
nous raconter des histoires on ne perd
pas de vue qu'ont vu que la situation
redevienne normale et qu'en janvier 21
ans on puisse prêt à présenter notre
programmation régulière ici louis
philippe ouimet radio canada montréal